le 26 avril c'était en 86 la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl explosé 16 ans
plus tard nous avons déjà largement
évoqué les conséquences dramatiques pour
les populations de cette explosion mais
on peut s'en indigner ou le contraire
aujourd'hui se développe autour de la
centrale nucléaire
une forme de tourisme bien particulier
paul ii
à première vue personne ne voudrait
passer ses vacances ici
mais cette centrale nucléaire n'est pas
n'importe laquelle tchernobyl 16 ans
après une destination un peu
particulière qu une agence de voyages
ukrainienne propose dans son catalogue
et tout est prévu pour mettre le
touriste en condition cette femme entrée
y sera votre guide
au programme visite d'une ville fantôme
ces appartements qui n'ont pas bougé
depuis l'explosion
cette visite aurait même des vertus
pédagogiques je pense que tous ceux qui
se préoccupent de leur avenir et de
celui de leurs enfants devraient visiter
au moins une fois dans leur vie
le résultat de ce que peut provoquer la
technologie moderne et voici looten
préfabriqué situé à quelques kilomètres
du site
grande est plutôt bien entretenus les
chambres disposent de tout le confort
moderne
mais pour l'instant comme le frigo elles
sont désespérément vides lagence attend
les premiers candidats au voyage
certaines conditions sont tout de même
requise bourillon mais dès ce show
montreront seulement ce qui est sûr les
familles et les enfants de moins de 18
ans ne sont pas autorisés et les groupes
qui ne pourront pas se promener
librement en fin de journée vous pourrez
même rencontré une des rares familles
encore dans la région pourrait même
partager avec eux un bon repas ces
garanties
tout vient directement du jardin